if this weather has you wanting some
good comfort food Carson kitchen is your
spot in joining us to tell us more is
executive chef Scott Simon and director
of operations David English welcome guys
thank you thank you for having a big day
for some comfort food
just getting the smells in this kitchen
I'm like oh my goodness and tell us
about the the comfort food you have at
Carson well what we do at Carson kitchen
is we tend to take like a normal style
thing and change the vessel or the the
food to something a little bit different
a little trickier right so in our
Alfredo dish here everybody's used to
kind of the chicken alfredo right here
we have the uh rabbit Alfredo but in
here we use the poblano peppers and then
we have uh some rabbit of course and
then fettuccine finishes it off what an
interesting take on a classic dish I
love it you guys are so Innovative at
cartoon kitchen and it smells fantastic
this is just one of the few dishes that
you can get there what are some of the
other amazing Comfort Foods if you like
spicy this one's definitely for you you
got the hot duck uh Nashville style so
very spicy Cherry pepper relish Serrano
mayo and then you got your Hot Tots too
oh my gosh I my stomach is growling
right now and it's not just about the
food a Carson kitchen even though well
we can't miss the final dishes this is
our classic bacon Jam that's been on the
menu since day one can I please eat that
looks amazing it has a very different
amount of flavors to it spicy vinegary
uh sweet definitely one of my favorites
from day one for sure perfect to share
or if you want to just have it put it by
yourself David tell us about some of the
great drinks that you guys have there so
so today we're going to be making for
you a kind of our take on a classic
bee's knees it's a gin based cocktail a
little bit of honey in there so we use
smoked honey we actually use on our menu
so kind of bringing a little bit more
depth of flavor and add a little bit of
quince preserves to it let's make this
now you guys call this a oh an angry
Tony an angry Tony yeah so our owner's
best friend owns a b a beehive uh kind
of farm yes in Connecticut so we named
it after him okay so what are you
putting in this so the first thing I put
in is a little bit of lemon juice then
we have the smoked honey here and the
Gin so it'll be three quarter ounce of
lemon juice about an ounce of honey two
ounces of the Gin here
we're pouring a little slow for me today
oh that's okay because I'm just ready to
inhale the spoon and then a little a
little scoop of uh Prince preserves okay
and then we'll just go ahead and Shake
It Up what's really cool about this
cocktail is we have kind of a Whimsical
presentation for it
so we actually so when you're a kid you
know remember when you put like honey on
toast or anything oh yeah so we've got
one of these cute little uh honey bear
vessels and then we just end up putting
it right inside the honey bear vessel
there and then we'll
I'm thinking like a rabbit Alfredo and
bears oh my this is the way to go
where's Carson Kitchen located where can
people go and check you guys out so
Carson kitchen is in downtown Las Vegas
right off Fremont Street uh Carson and
sixth um hours where hours were open or
Monday through Thursday 11 30 a.m to 10
p.m Friday Saturday 11 30 to 11 and then
on Sundays we do brunch from 11 to 4 and
then we continue on to dinner till 10
p.m amazing service amazing food so
Innovative I am all about this and um
thank you guys so much